الفاينانشال تايمز تناولت السياقه الزمنيه
للضربه الامريكيه التي استهدفت قياديا في
الحشد الشعبي بالعراق وقالت انها تاتي في
ظل الحرب المستمره بين اسرائيل وحماس مما
يزيد من خطر نشوب صراع اقليمي اوسع كما
تاتي الضربه بعد يومين من استهداف القيادي
البارز في حماس صالح العاروري في
لبنان في صحيفه لوموند نقرا عن معادله
صعبه يواجهها حزب الله بعد اغتيال صالح
العاروري فمن جهه لا يمكنه الا ان يرد على
ما يعتبره استفزازا من طرف اسرائيل في
معقله ومن جهه اخرى فان اي رد قوي يخاطر
بجر حزب الله الى حرب شامله مع اسرائيل ظل
يتحاشاها منذ الثامن من
اكتوبر في صحيفه ها ارتس مقال ينصح
الاسرائيليين بتاييد وقف الحرب اذا كانوا
يبحثون عن مصلحتهم واذا لم يكن ذلك من اجل
غزه وسكانها يستعرض المقال العديد من
تداعيات الحرب على حياه الاسرائيليين
اليوميه منذ بدايه الحرب منها تعطل
الدراسه وزياده الاعباء الاقتصاديه وتراجع
الاستثمار وارتفاع معدل الجريمه وحوادث
استخدام الاسلحه داخل المجتمع بوتيره
مقلقه في صحيفه نيويورك تايمز تقرير جاء
فيه ان المجتمع الاسرائيليه صدم بمؤسسه
الجيش التي تحضى لديه بتقدير كبير
باعتبارها قائ
على مجموعه من المبادئ الانسانيه يروج لها
باستمرار يذكر التقرير بحادثه مقتل
الرهائن الثلاثه في غزه بنيران الجيش
الاسرائيلي ثم يقول ان الشكوك تتزايد بين
الاسرائيليين بشان قواعد الاشتباك التي
يفرضها الجيش بينما تتعزز قناعه جماعات
حقوق الانسان بان اخفاقات الجيش في هذا
الجانب تتركز في اغلب الحالات في تعامله
مع
الفلسطينيين مجله فورين بوليسي نشرت مقالا
يجمل عده دروس يقول ان اسرائيل يجب ان
تستخلصها من هجوم حماس الهجوم اثبت ان
سياسه الردع غير مجديه وانه لا يمكن
الاعتماد فقط على الاجهزه الاستخباراتيه
من اجل انذار مبكر ولا على الدفاعات
متفوقه التكنولوجيا اكبر خطر على اسرائيل
وفق المقال داخلي وقتل المزيد من
الفلسطينيين يقوض سمعتها عبر
العالم